I couldn't bring myself to watch this
one because it looked too gross let's
see how well it Recaps the movie is set
in a dystopian future where pollution
and climate change have reduced the
world into a dark and dilapidated place
to cope with this the human body has
undergone numerous biological changes
some of them include The Disappearance
of physical pain and infectious diseases
moreover due to the scarcity of pure
water and food the human digestive
system has started changing the movie
opens up with a little eight-year-old
boy named Brecken playing at the beach
he appears to be having a good time but
his mother Juna warns him not to eat
anything he finds on the ground this
indicates that Brecken has a habit of
eating unwanted stuff after a while he
returns home and enters the washroom to
freshen himself up Bracken first brushes
his teeth then cleans his face but after
that he shockingly sits on the floor and
starts eating the plastic dust bin kept
there his teeth are so sharp and
advanced that he choose the hard
material without any trouble Juna
notices him in the ACT but doesn't say
is evident that she is tired of her
son's unnatural Behavior so at night she
decides to take matters into her own
hands when little Bracken goes to bed
Juna slowly approaches him holding a
pillow and puts it over his face Bracken
shouts for help but Juno presses the
pillow hard and suffocates him to death
while doing this she does not show a
single sign of guilt or remorse
following this junis sits on the toilet
seat calls her ex-husband Lang and
informs him that she killed Brecken she
also mentions that she never never
considered their son anything but a
monster and now that everything's over
she wants Lang to come home and take the
boy's corpse away as soon as Juna hangs
up Lang breaks down in tears devastated
that his only Offspring has been taken
away from him later that night he
arrives at the house but does not find
Yuna anywhere when he finally comes
across his son's body he once again
becomes emotional and starts crying the
scene then shifts to another place where
a person named Saul is sleeping in a
cocoon-like chamber supported by several
we learned that he is suffering from a
rare evolutionary disease which leaves
him in extreme Agony the major symptoms
of the condition are respiratory and
intestinal difficulties to cope with
this Saul sleeps in the cocoon-like bed
which helps him minimize the pain when
he wants to eat he sits on a special
chair that twitches and Spins to help
him digest food however it is a very
uncomfortable process and Saul no longer
feels like eating these days one morning
while he is in deep Sleep his girlfriend
Caprice enters the room and wakes him up
Saul complains that his machine bed is
not working properly as he is facing
trouble sleeping all night goddamn
spinny twitch bed they don't make him
like they used to in response Caprice
calms him down and reveals about the
test results they performed recently she
explains that Saul is developing a new
organ inside his body and this is why he
is experiencing pain she then inserts a
black tube inside his stomach and
observes the new organ Caprice tells him
that she cannot exactly figure out the
organ but it seems similar to a renal
gland afterward she takes him to the
National Organ registry to trademark his
new organ inside they meet the head of
the department whip it and his assistant
Timlin whippet assures the couple that
after the complete development of the
newly grown organ Saul will feel no pain
at all he then heads to his office to
prepare some documents while the two
women start shouting Timlin asks Caprice
what they do for a living and the latter
responds that they are a performance
artist couple their shows usually
involve Caprice removing the extra
organs from Saul's body in front of a
live audience they use specially
designed equipment to perform their
shows screw Avatar I want to see that
later whip it along with his assistant
straps all to its share and begin
investigating his new organ they also
leave a mark on it so that they can
track the changes and its effects
Caprice tries to film the entire process
with a camera attached to a ring but
Timlin stops her from doing so after the
procedure is completed solid Caprice
Leaf but not before inviting Timlin and
whip it to their new upcoming art
performance in the following scene two
technicians arrive at Saul's place to
help him readjust his bed and share they
are from the same company that
manufactured these machines during their
shift the technicians Snoop around the
house and come across an advanced
autopsy unit one of the technicians
realizes that the unit is an old one
which was discontinued by the company a
long time ago when she asks Caprice
about it the latter reveals that it's
the same machine which helps her perform
her shows with Saul this seen then fast
forwards to the day of their art
performance we see Saul sleeping inside
the autopsy unit while Caprice is
dressed in a dark red dress equipped
with some buttons under her chest the
buttons actually control the arms of the
autopsy machine while performing surgery
on saw they are surrounded by a huge
crowd including whippet and Tamlin after
a while the show begins and Caprice with
the help of the machine cuts through
Saul and exposes his newly grown organ
the procedure is a gruesome one but Saul
doesn't feel any pain in fact he is
enjoying every single second of it okay
never mind I I'd pref I want to see
Avatar please as the show comes to an
end the crowd erupts and shears and
expresses their satisfaction at the
wonderful sight among them is Lang who
is seen eating a dark chocolate bar
after the successful performance Timlin
approaches Saul and applauds his talent
she even goes on to say that she felt
aroused watching him in response Saul
says that he is happy he can make her
feel that way as the two continue
chatting Caprice notices them and
becomes jealous however she acts
professional and chooses not to
intervene meanwhile a random guy eats
the chocolate bar left by a Lang and
instantly chokes to death the next day
Timlin and whippet are questioned by
detective cope about the case of Saul he
says that he works for the government
and is investigating the individuals who
are trying to modify their organs
however instead of revealing
confidential information Timlin defends
Saul saying he is doing all this just
for his performances elsewhere Saul
attends a crazy show where a performance
artist has grown ears all around his
body some of them have come out of his
hands legs and even private parts you
might even say he enjoys the sound of
his own farts after a while as Saul
prepares to leave Lang arrives there and
confronts him with a strange request he
wants Saul and his wife to conduct a
show where they will perform an autopsy
on brecken's body Lang asserts that
there is a surprise for them inside the
boy's stomach hearing this Saul becomes
intrigued and says that he will think
about it before walking away later all
reaches home and chats with his
girlfriend regarding the ideas suggested
by Lang Caprice agrees right away but
mentions that they need to modify their
autopsy unit to perform the act after
this she lies inside the machine and
checks the parts that need to be
modified at night Saul sneaks out of the
house and meets detective cope it is
then revealed that he is working for the
detective to find out the individuals
who are performing bodily modifications
illegally Saul reveals that he has been
asked to visit a cosmetic surgeon and
cope gives him permission to follow the
lead the following day the two
technicians from earlier arrive at
Saul's residence and start modifying the
autopsy unit as instructed by Caprice in
the meantime Saul visits the cosmetic
surgeon who suggests that he install a
zipper in his stomach with the help of
this he can display his newly grown
organ to the audience any time he
desires Saul agrees without any
hesitation and goes under the knife
after the surgery he returns home and
shows his newly installed zipper to
Caprice surprisingly she is so impressed
by the zipper that she kneels down and
starts licking pleasuring paw oh yeah X
my Z sweet humps in the next scene Saul
visits the prison and meets Juna to ask
about her son Brecken The Psychotic
woman who still doesn't regret her
actions says that her son was not a
normal human but a monster he used to
eat plastic and other harmful materials
with ease Juna also reveals that he was
deliberately created by his father Lang
Who belongs to a revolutionary group
this group is Infamous for tweaking
internal organs and modifying other body
parts on the other hand Lang enters a
factory-like warehouse where his friends
are working hard to prepare chocolates
from Plastics and other toxic waste here
we get to know that that random guy at
the bar died because of the consumption
of toxic waste Lang then talks to his
colleagues and tells them that he will
soon let the public know about his son's
unique ability to digest plastic the
next day Caprice attends an art show
where a female cuts and makes scars on
her face this is so much better than
Hamilton Caprice is really impressed by
the scars and the Elegance in creating
them later she is approached by the
Performing lady who invites her to make
modifications on her face Caprice thanks
for a brief second and a grease
afterwards she returns home with a scar
modification on her forehead and Saul
seems to like it Caprice tells him that
she wants to lead the autopsy they're
going to perform on Brecken and he
agrees to let her do it later that day
the couple heads to Lang's place and
takes a look at brecken's dead body
seeing his innocent face Caprice becomes
a bit anxious and starts having second
thoughts about the autopsy however Lang
reassures her that it is fine and
explains that he wants to make a
statement to the public his ultimate
goal is to stop the government from
hunting down the evolutionists Lang also
talks about Saul's feeding problem and
provides him with a candy bar as a
solution the latter is a bit skeptical
about eating it so he simply keeps it in
his pocket following this slang reveals
how his group members modified their
digestive systems to be able to consume
and digest plastic he also tells them
that his son Brecken was the only human
born with a natural digestive system
capable of absorbing nutrients out of
plastic the information leaves the
couple stunned and they become even more
motivated to perform the autopsy
following this the scene cuts to the day
of the show Caprice Begins the autopsy
on the dead boy while Timlin Lang and
several other people are watching from
the audience all the people are
anticipating that they will see
something unique inside brecken's body
as the show has been marketed
extensively however to their dismay
Caprice discovers that the boy has a
normal digestive system just like anyone
else this leaves Lang speechless and
realizing that his plan has failed
miserably he storms out of the place he
then sits on the staircase and begins
crying imagine being sad because your
son's autopsy disappointed a live
audience shortly after the two
technicians who claim that they
represent the equipment company approach
him at first they try to comfort him but
when he is distracted they put power
drills into his brain and finish him off
this finally reveals that they too work
for the government after the show Saul
meets detective cope and inquires if
anyone tampered with bracken's body the
detective confidently reveals that he
changed the boy's internal organs as he
didn't want the public to know about the
evolution of humans the one who assisted
him in this mission was none other than
Timlin as Saul lessons in disbelief cope
further reveals that Lang has been taken
care of by his associates now they won't
have to worry about any Revolution
hearing this Saul becomes upset as he
had started sympathizing with Lang the
poor man only wanted to raise a voice
about his kind so that the public would
treat them like normal humans hence Saul
refuses to continue working for cup and
walks away from there the plastic tummy
people must be heard the next day he
struggles to feed himself despite
sitting on his special chair the pain
inside his body has only become worse
and he is unable to move his limbs
properly when nothing works Saul decides
to try one of the candy bars that Lang
provided him before surprisingly as soon
as he swallows the first bite the pain
in his body goes away Saul then locks
into caprice's eyes passes a smile and
sheds a tear this means that Saul's body
has also evolved and he is now capable
of digesting toxic waste the movie ends
with Saul sitting still on the chair
which has stopped moving subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching